here's a question a hundred and twenty
thousand dollars suddenly inexplicably
and appeared in your bank account would
you spend it no you wouldn't I
definitely would not well you're afraid
a pennsylvania couple did would you i
wouldn't spend it i wouldn't tell
anybody that might just sit there me
like let's see what happens plays out
that would be good advice well the
pennsylvania couple did the bank
apparently transferred that money into
the account of Robert and Tiffany
Williams by mistake in two and a half
weeks they spent most of the money the
way you would have party over here yep
they spot an SUV two four-wheelers a
camper a car trailer they paid their
bills they did car repairs they even
gave fifteen thousand dollars to friends
nice nice except they're now facing
felony theft charges
there's overdraft fees the bank called
and said not only you have to give the
money back you have to pay the other day
if you don't have it you're getting an
overdraft fee you have to put the money
back in the proper person's account and
now they've got to get the money from
this couple well I heard they tried to
work it out with a couple and then the
couple stopped answering their phone
calls so now they're gonna get charges
Carl I would show guilty
you didn't answer Anthony it's awfully
tempting it is tempting but I think I'd
take I'd take Tony's approach I'd sit
there and just see what happened and if
after about two weeks the money was
still there I go it's mine the camper in
the four-wheeler yeah